i guess that takes a sore next um super
obvious
conversation which is your recent move
to miami
uh which you've been vocal about and a
number of other people have already
shervins in miami a bunch of other
people have moved to miami
obviously austin is the other premier
destination for people leaving the bay
area
we're seeing uh uh reno uh
seattle's pretty common as well
seattle's very i know the media has been
tracking that but as far as i can tell
a reasonable fraction of people i know
professionally or socially
that have left the bay area have also
migrated to seattle
and it's really interesting to
have been in the bay area for as long as
you were
i've been here for five or six years and
to see
this golden goose this incredible well
of innovation jobs and this tax basis
overnight because of the pandemic and
for the mismanagement of the city
to go away what is your estimate in
terms of
post pandemic what san francisco the
city the government and the industry
looks like
well it's been this you know to some
extent there's been a trend against the
bay area and against san francisco
specifically
for somewhere between three and five
years as i've pointed out publicly
before when we look at our
portfolio at founders fund of the most
important companies
and i'd measure that by like you know
our carrying value our dollars invested
more than half of our companies over the
last three to five years that are the
most important companies in the
portfolio are outside san francisco and
the bay area
and that's been true so this is this lag
this is an indicator
i think that happened was it just that
san francisco was filled up
no i think there's some cultural reasons
i think there's some political reasons
i actually think there's some
entitlement reasons which you know
certainly has been glossed over a little
bit recently
but fundamentally i think there was
reasons that companies outside the bay
area were thriving
before the pandemic i think it was let's
go over those i think it was harder for
people who are sitting here
like myself with strong networks here to
imagine
abandoning the network effect of being
here
um although we were making more and more
investments outside the bay area and
watching them succeed
it was still harder to imagine ourselves
like removing ourselves from
like the center of the network and then
obviously the pandemic caused
a mental shift if nothing else people
laughed
voluntarily sometimes on a temporary
basis but for a substantial amount of
time three six nine
plus months and realized that actually
there are better places
to raise a family better places to enjoy
living
and they don't necessarily want to come
back
and if a reasonable number of those
people don't come back then the argument
for being in the bay area which was
always
that there's a network of active talent
basically
atrophies or is completely eliminated
and so
it did take like a massive tidal wave
you know a macro
shift or you know an unexpected black
swan
to clarify for people like me that were
central nodes
you know in a social graph you know of
the bay area of silicon valley
that you know maybe things are changing
faster and maybe they can be rebuilt
elsewhere
i don't know if i would have had that
epiphany absolutely you know
extraordinary one-time event
but then once you see people leaving and
then you study the data of how many
people are leaving and how many
companies are thriving outside the bay
area
you start questioning all the
assumptions you've had previously so
let's look at a couple examples what's
probably the most interesting company
um in the last year probably shopify
certainly yeah somewhere not
yeah not either certainly not the bay
area not in california i mean but
they're not even in toronto or vancouver
they're in um
yeah they're automatically like ottawa
yeah
they have some people in toronto um but
it's not even like the classic waterloo
you know engineering culture um the most
interesting company i've been involved
in
the last year let's say has been a
company called fair
uh you know i've made seed investment
i've been funding them for like
three or four years they're going to be
a very successful
10 to 100 billion dollar company they've
never had a single engineer in san
francisco
headquarters is technically here but
they've never hired a single engineer in
san francisco